check GPT is truly a fascinating
technology changing how we interact with
language it's the result of years of
research and development by open AI who
have trained the model on a massive
amount of Text data to create a machine
that can easily understand and generate
human-like text imagine you are a
digital marketer looking to make a big
impact on your next campaign chair GPT
can help you do that charge gbt uses
natural language processing or NLP which
can assist you in creating compelling
human-like copy for your website social
media and email marketing it can even
generate product descriptions and AD
copy that is engaging and optimized for
search engines using chat GPT will save
time and increase your productivity
allowing you to focus on other important
aspects of your campaign and with its
ability to generate multiple text
variations you can test and Define your
messaging to find the perfect tone and
language that resonates with your target
audience get ready to revolutionize your
digital marketing game with the help of
this video you will gain a deeper
understanding of how 10 GPT can
supercharge your efforts as a content
creator or digital marketer say goodbye
to mundane tasks and hello to a 10-fold
boost in productivity let's dive in ever
since open AI launched chatgpt it has
been making waves in every field meet
academic marketing engineering or
content writing so here's a little
trivia for you who are the investors in
open AI the company behind the
development of CIA jpd and your options
are option A Elon Musk and Sam Altman
option b Jeff Bezos and satyana data
option C Mark Zuckerberg and Larry Page
option D segma and masayoshi Sun Drop
your answer in the comment section below
but before we begin let me ask you if
you are aiming to get certified in
digital marketing and want to build a
career in digital marketing then Unleash
Your digital marketing potential with
simpler get ahead of the competition and
upskill with simple learns IMT ghaziabad
digital marketing program
learn from industry experts gain
hands-on experience with real world
projects and master inbound and outbound
marketing strategies to drive business
growth
join our community of successful
Learners today and become a digital
marketing Pro in no time to learn more
about this digital marketing course
check the link in the description box
below
okay then let's get started there are
many uses of chat jpt in digital
marketing its main USB is smart human
sounding content writing we can command
it to write content related to marketing
first on our agenda is an ad copy there
are various ways to go about it but we
must understand that no matter how much
content sounds like humans it is still a
piece of content written by an AI so you
have to give detailed and precise
queries to get the best results let's
start by giving it a basic command like
write an ad copy
foreign
content let's give this query more
content like write an ad copy for simply
learn digital marketing Master's course
[Music]
now as you can see it gave us a more
precise ad copy we can also ask to make
it longer or shorter let's give it a
next query can you make it longer
foreign
it gave us a long version of that same
content now let's try to convert it into
email newsletters we digital marketers
often send emails to promote our
products and services so let's give it a
query as can you convert it to email
newsletters
yeah
as you can see it has generated an email
with a subject line and body that is
enticing and engaging to read we can
also utilize chat GPT to correct grammar
or change the tone of the content for
example let's enter a new query what is
Facebook
[Music]
it has given us a journal overview of
Facebook now let's ask it to rephrase it
more engagingly and in a digital
marketing context we can give queries
like can you make it more engaging and
relatable with digital marketing
[Music]
as you can see it has completely
replaced it and it is more interesting
to read it as well GPT can also help
with keyword research so let's try it we
will give a query as suggest more such
keywords for a digital marketing core
site
[Music]
and Bola it has completed a work we used
to spend 10 to 15 minutes in a few
seconds you can request to write blogs
as well let's give it a query to search
for some keywords for the blog suggest
keywords to write a blog on digital
marketing
it gave us some keywords you can ask it
to reduce these topics based on search
volume to get maximum results let's ask
it to narrow it down to five topics
based on keywords volume
[Music]
here we have some suggestions let's pick
a topic content writing and ask it to
write an article on content writing
[Music]
here we have an article for the blog
let's use chatgpt to se optimize it
let's first request it to give us meta
title and meta description
[Music]
here we have meta title and meta
description for this article we can even
request it to give us an SEO optimized
URL link
we can also request it to write the SC
optimized version of this article just
give it a command as also can you as you
optimize this article to improve Google
search results
[Music]
here we have fully SEO optimized article
with meta title and meta description
where the SEO optimized URL chat GPT can
also be used to train your customer
service chat boards but we can discuss
the process in some other video chatgpt
is well versed with its content writing
capabilities it can even help you write
product marketing campaigns let's try it
with this query the queries write a
product marketing campaign Force
Implement digital marketing courses
foreign
Ty has done it again this campaign looks
interesting and it will be able to
generate more leads for simple lens
courses chat jbd can also be used to
write scripts for YouTube videos let's
give it a query as write a script for
five minute YouTube video promoting
simply learn and its digital marketing
courses
foreign
[Music]
script along with few suggestions for
video editor on where to put logos and
clips to make the video more engaging if
you are a content creator and you don't
know how to approach other content
creators for a collaborative video then
chatgpt can help you with that it can
help you writing collaboration emails as
well my next query will be to write a
collaborative email for a YouTube video
on digital marketing
[Music]
foreign
and I wrote a customer collaboration
email that looks professional plus easy
to read and understand I hope this video
helped you understand more about chatgpt
uses in digital marketing and if you are
a digital marketer or a content creator
this will help you out in increasing
your productivity 10 volts if you like
this video and want more such videos
then let us know in the comment section
below and also hit the like button and
share it with your peers until next time
stay safe and keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd